um
tell me the story about when you were
shot was it five times by ak yeah five
times with an ak i was
uh 18 years old
um
wrong place wrong time type [ __ ] parked
in
in the driveway and you know
two people came up and sprayed up the
whole car bro we had 36 36 holes in the
car
how many people were in the car three of
us anybody not make it
i'm the only one that got hit oh [ __ ] so
there was holes throughout that whole
car um you know my brother was actually
with us my brother was in another
car and behind us or whatnot
um it was
it was tragic bro you know what i'm
saying it was something that you know i
relive
every day because i'm still dealing with
pain i'm still dealing with
issues from you know that were caused
from that i got hit two times in my back
two times in my side and one time in my
arm i'm missing a kidney a spleen
half a liver half a pancreas
both my lungs collapsed
my aorta was torn completely
they had to um
reconstruct it
i was in a coma for a month and a half
it was insane my mom would be by my
bedside
the girls that i was messing with at the
time were by my bedside like my homies
would all pull up like at one point the
doctor came out with my bed after the
first surgery and seen
300 people there and couldn't believe
that there was 300 people even in the
hospital right he's like all of you guys
are here for bed one and they're like
yeah
he was like wow he's like well let me
tell you guys something he wants to live
he's fighting so the first surgery he's
like but i can't promise you the second
surgery is going to go the same
when i came out of the second surgery he
told my homies
he's here he's going to stay and they
went crazy they want to go barbecue and
do all kinds of [ __ ] they want to party
you know
is that the only time you were shot yeah
there's only time that's that was more
than enough that was more than enough
right
that's some real [ __ ]
damn
yeah i was yeah and then uh yeah they uh
so i had um these bunch of different
you know little machines
tagged to me and one of the nurses came
into the um
to the room where i was at
and i couldn't talk because i had a tube
like you know in my throat and my side
of my um
right here my like underarm yeah just
tubes everywhere basically and i
couldn't really speak i couldn't speak
at all
um the lady came in and was like oh i'm
gonna take you off of these machines i'm
gonna try to walk you and i had just got
shot like a week and a half before so i
was like [ __ ] me like i was looking at
her like
no like the only thing i could do was
kind of
you know shake my head kind of get her
to understand that i'm not ready to walk
she's like oh you're fine she's
unplugging all this [ __ ] and i'm like
like no like you know what i'm saying in
my head i was screaming but i couldn't
right say nothing
so she took me off of the bed sat me up
and i guess when she sat me up uh air
bubble wrote uh like right rose to my
into my brain oh [ __ ] so i passed out
i passed out when she did that because i
didn't i didn't know what was going on
but the air bubble
rose to my brain and
it caused something up there to where it
made me pass out
um the doctors came and tried to get me
back they couldn't then the doctor
finally got me back with somebody else's
stuff so
um when i woke up he's like move your
right hand so you know i move my right
hand he's like move your right leg so i
move my right leg and he's like move
your left hand and i tried and nothing
would move move your left leg it
wouldn't move either it was parallel i
was paralyzed from half of my half of my
body
so they had to take me to long beach
memorial hospital and they put me in a
diverse tank wow which i guess the
divers when they dive too deep they get
those air bubbles yeah what do they
bring so they deal with the same stuff
in a different form so they put me in a
diver's tank to where it was like at an
angle my feet were towards the ground my
face was like
up here
um
they put i still remember they put on a
movie they brought like a little sliding
screen with a movie and uh they put on
something about mary
i remember they still put that movie on
and then like within three minutes to
four minutes i was out so i guess they
gassed that like tank wow you know they
put you to sleep so put me to sleep and
then i guess they turn up the pressure
while you're sleeping they brought me
out and he's like move your right hand i
moved in right leg moved in move your
left it wouldn't budge it's like thrown
back in so they put me back in there
i don't know i don't know how long i'm
staying in there again but they put the
same movie back on
turn the gases on or whatever and oh
when they finally pull me out he's like
move your left hand
i was able to move my left hand
today crazy for sure for sure i have one
of the top 50 doctors in the world his
name was dr asensio he's from brazil wow
he was at usc hospital he definitely is
a blessing and you know if i ever had
the chance to
show my appreciation i would man you
know what i'm saying this is definitely
a blessing to have been under his yeah
cause you you know if you don't have the
right doctor they might have just been
like oh you're [ __ ] that's that was
what they were saying when i was walking
in they're like this one's done and that
doctor was like nah bring him to me he
was just there doing like
a study or a seminar
that's
man one of the top 50 in the world bro
that's big